Now, the language of war
is not only confusing--
the non-war war itself
is confusing.
So here's what I'm gonna do,
guys. I'm gonna
break it down for you
in a new segment we're calling
Explaining Complex Stuff
Using the Latest
and Most Accessible
Pop Culture References.
♪ ♪
Okay. That was pretty good.
Okay, tonight, we're using
Game of Thrones
and Beyoncé's Lemonade,
all right?
-Okay. Very good.
-(whooping)
Okay, so here's the thing,
Syria is a Westeros,
a war-torn country ruled
by rich assholes
who murder their own people,
okay?
That's Assad. Right?
Now, there are two main groups
who want regime change.
Let's call the first one
angry rebels,
represented by Beyoncé.
And, boy, let me tell you, man.
Those are some angry ground
forces rebelling right there.
All right?
Yeah.
Okay, now, the other main group
who wants regime change is ISIS,
i.e., the White Walkers.
Right? Yeah.
Because they're scary
as (bleep),
and at some point, everyone's
gonna have to deal with them,
right? Now,
Assad is bolstered by Putin,
obviously represented here
by Jay Z.
Right? Right? Yes, yes, yes!
Because he-he and Beyoncé seem
to be in an open war
against each other, and that's
making everyone uncomfortable.
And, of course, Beyoncé
is in her black power phase,
so, of course, she's also at war
with the White Walkers.
You know what I'm saying.
Right? Okay.
Now, the United States
is Khaleesi,
because she's across the ocean
and has superior air power she's
been unwilling to use so far.
But Khaleesi is funding Beyoncé
by subscribing to Tidal
to listen to her Lemonade album.
Exactly, exactly.
Also, we're not getting
into a war with Jay Z,
because that's a war
we probably can't win.
We're not stupid.
Now, the United Nations
is Hodor.
Big presence
but nothing to say, really.
And Solange Knowles is inva...
is involved in this mess
somehow, but it's not clear how.
Uh, she may have killed Jon Snow
for breaking his vows.
Nobody really knows.
And Rachael Ray is Turkey.
She got pulled into a flame war
that has nothing to do with her
except proximity.
Why is she in this?!
It doesn't make sense!
She just wants this to end!
Okay. So there you have it,
Syria perfectly explained
through the power
of pop culture.
♪ ♪
Okay. Uh, look, the fact is,
if we're gonna defeat ISIS,
we need all hands on deck,
and it's okay to say that!
Coded language is...
coded language is keeping it 55,
and this nation needs Obama
to keep it 100.